it's back-breaking work barefoot and
without so much as gloves to protect
themselves workers are taking freighters
apart
one of the biggest so-called ship
cemeteries in Chittagong the smoke
billowing from the blow torches makes it
hard to breathe
Mohammed Alamgir has worked here since
he was just nine years old our lives are
in our own hands they don't care about
us they don't want to take care of us if
they paid us more they'd make less money
for themselves that's why we barely get
anything Alamgir makes just five euros a
day around 20,000 people work here
although it's dangerous work none of
them have accident or health insurance
and that's despite Salvage firms making
about 1 million euros per ship accidents
are very common ships are stripped down
to a steel shell which has then taken
apart by a swarm of workers armed with
blow torches the metal is taken ashore
and melted down for Alamgir it's a 70
hour working week if I don't do this
work I'll have nothing to eat I won't be
able to take care of my family that's
why I'm forced to do this if I missed a
single day of work I wouldn't have
enough money to last the month but
there's nothing I can do about it I'll
carry on for as long as my body can
endure it we don't have any money and my
father is unemployed because he can't
work he'll be very angry with me if I
don't work there's just nowhere to make
money
the International Maritime Organization
curved the dangerous job of processing
scrap in its Hong Kong Convention but
that's largely been ignored having only
been ratified by Norway Congo and France